special course in Tech 82 that we um
plan to have intensively for the next 3
days I'm going to give you all a an OD
on uh on this particular system um uh
this is um some I'll probably do only
once in my life um because I I don't
know if I'll understand the system as
well as I do now at any other time in my
life um and uh I think it's an exciting
time for the development of tech because
here's when uh it's beginning to to uh
move out and meet a lot of a lot of
different kinds of computers around the
world it's it's quite an experiment in
portable software that we're doing I
think at a for a program of this kind
and um at this scale to try to uh make
make it work on lots of different
machines and I'm I'm pleased that every
that uh so many people are participating
in this experiment with us um now the uh
lectures that I'm giving are are on
videotape as well as being you know in
this live uh uh thing that we're doing
here and uh the people watching on
videotape will presumably be doing it
after Tech is debugged because I hope to
debug it next week to I mean to finish
it next week um uh so um at the time
that the people are watching on tape
they'll probably have a slightly
different collection of handouts than
you do in the audience right now now the
the three handouts that you were given
this morning uh one is the write up um
Tech
82 um and this one I by the time people
are watching a tape I think it'll be
published in a book um then the the
first part of that book will contain the
tech user manual which I haven't
finished writing yet uh instead uh in
the audience all you people have is a
brief summary of what the what the that
language te2 is going to contain then
the other two handn notes you got this
morning one is uh this one called the
web system of structured documentation
and this is uh uh uh the other one is
called
techware and the the web system is of
course this the the one that we're using
to to make uh uh to make it possible to
do system programming in Pascal and to
make it portable and the um and techware
is a collection of four different uh
auxiliary programs that you'll find
useful in installing Tech uh the first
program is uh is simply uh to print out
the string pool file we'll talk about
that later second program is to convert
um uh font metric files to a symbolic
format the third program goes back from
the symbolic format to the uh uh pack
binary format and the last example is
how to is a symbolic printer of our DVI
files the device independent output of
text now uh By the time people are
watching a videotape I think these two
uh handouts I just mentioned are going
to be uh Stanford reports and so they uh
uh if I refer to those that that'll mean
a certain Stanford report uh finally at
the end of your blue uh at the end of
your Tech 82 listing there are some
appendices and those will probably be
published in Tugboat by the time uh
anybody watches on uh watches this tape
the um dependencies are related to a
test program for the for the system and
uh uh the idea will be that somebody can
run this test program on the system and
uh and compare their answers to what uh
uh to what I think the right answers are
and uh that and so we'll be talking
about the test program later on
too those are the sources for the thing
now now as far as the organization goes
um uh we have three days here and four
hours each day we're going to meet 9:30
sharp uh we're going to start at 9:30
sharp every morning um and 2:00 sharp
every afternoon and we run 9:30 to 10:30
take a break till 11: start at 11: sharp
11: to 12:00 then break till 2:00 then
we'll go 2: to 3 and 3:30 to
4:30 that's what I meant by overdosing
of uh U of this thing um now in in this
time I expect that I'll be able to um to
to make you familiar with so that you
you'll feel that uh uh you understand
what what all this document is doing um
uh at least uh where to look for the
other answers not that you'll have
proved it correct in your mind or
anything like that but I believe that
it's possible in about 40 hours of
reading um not counting coffee breaks
uh to to just go through and and
actually understand each module of the
code um and uh and convince yourself
that it's actually working and of course
hardly anybody's ever going to do that
you you'll just skim it and say well if
I ever need to know about this module
then I'll look look further and
understand it but if you had that as
your goal uh suppose that I was for
example having a contest to see who can
find the uh the each each remaining bug
uh first and I was I was giving out $100
for every winner like that if you had to
do that I think you would get to the end
of it uh in 40 hours and um uh if if you
were motivated well that's a a rough
estimate as to how as to how much uh uh
it might be to comprehend all of this
code now it's this uh the the computer
file that generated this book was about
3/4 of a million bytes long um and so
that's about how much uh uh chance there
was for typographical errors in it uh uh
you know I mean each one of those bites
could have been could have been uh misp
punched and then there's a chance for
bugs too and and so on um it's about as
correct now as as it would be if this
was a book on mathematics uh which had
theorems and proofs in it uh
unfortunately computer programs also
have to work and so I'm I'm not quite
not quite there to that level yet now I
I know that people in the audience here
have a large variety of backgrounds some
people are um are uh
at least three of you I think have have
implemented the previous version of tech
uh know every every bite of that of that
implementation um and uh and uh and on
the other hand there are people here who
probably won't be um writing the the
system in code themselves but they they
want to use Tech heavily and they just
want to get a good feeling for what's
inside of it and uh now uh so how can I
uh make everybody happy um in this way
well I I think probably that my best
strategy is going to be to to not go too
fast but to also but but to those in the
audience who are going to be users and
not system people should try to imagine
that they were system people um it won't
hurt just to to keep that in mind as if
you were as if they were you going to
implement it um you don't have to
afterward but it gives you the right
frame of mind to understand uh the the
kind of questions because what we're
going to do is we're going to to say to
consider as our goal to to understand
this this complex piece of software and
uh and to um look at um and to uh uh to
see how the different parts uh uh fit
together uh with each other and then and
and then then will'll get a uh even if
you're only going to be a user later on
and not ever touch this code you're
going to have a pretty good feeling for
how this uh complex piece of software is
going to respond when you do certain
when you use it in certain
way
um now let's see can you hear me all
right now the mic's no is it possible to
turn the audio off better in the in the
audience cuz I I got to save my voice
for the okay is that any better no it's
not working at all it's not there's no
mic there's no amplification at all oh
here comes the man hi is there a way to
turn on audio in
the
okay it's it's this thing
no okay okay is this ah
wow okay now you're getting some
audio okay well welcome to Tech
82 you you heard it you at least if you
laughed you probably heard that I said
that once before right okay now the four
the four lectures that we're talking the
four things we have today are are the
fundamental ground level things on which
we're going to base uh things later
don't miss any of these um the the first
hour is listed as reading web programs
and the next hour representation of
strings inside the program the third it
will be the data structures for boxes
and glue and the last um will be
representation of control
sequences and uh those are in other
words uh the the key things first we're
going to find out how to read the
program and then we're going to find out
how it represents things in inside of
itself in order to get any further we
have to see how how the uh uh how the
inside of tech looks so that we can see
how how it deals with the things that we
know um uh appear on the outside
tomorrow's lectures are going to be
about the um uh the uh uh main
processing routines of tech the syntax
routines at at the beginning um then the
semantic routines and then in the
afternoon I'm going to talk about how
Tech breaks paragraphs into lines and uh
and how how it does
hyphenation um on Friday we're going to
have four lectures that are primarily
addressing the U the the system
dependent issues the things that are
most important to the people who are
going to be installing Tech um and those
in other words uh uh uh the things that
uh that are most critical to the to the
uh uh uh portability question and um so
the first hour is talk about scanning of
file names because we want to uh make
Tech uh fit in with the local operating
system and every operating system has
different ways of referring to these
names uh and um then we're going to talk
about the font metric files and what
they look like inside and how and uh so
you can understand TFM files um in the
afternoon we're going to talk about the
DVI files the and uh how and the
problems of uh of initializing the
production program getting it going in
the first place so those are all uh
things where we're really bit pushing
pretty much on Friday namely the the
file names um is the is a syntactical
problem that's different at different
installations the TFM and DVI files are
binary files that um you have to
understand because they'll be on your
systems and uh then we have to also talk
about about what you do to to to bring
uh to bring bootstrapping process of
bringing things into
existence okay any questions so
far now the uh I was delighted yesterday
to get in the mail the new the new
August edition of computer magazine has
a cover called the evolution of ethernet
and I maybe I can Flash that well no you
won't be able to see it I'll just hold
it up uh uh we might be able to get it
on the screen later but uh it's got a
beautiful picture of a web on it
um with drop slets of water on the web
and it's just like you'd find in the
sier club calendar or something and uh
what I'm talking about the first hour is
the web system of documentation and uh
and web is uh is here thought of as
something that's not going to to um ens
snare us but uh but something that has a
structure like a network structure in
fact they use the web to illustrate
ethernet um which is a probably doesn't
have that structure at all but but the
web and net are
are somewhat linguistically related and
and they're related also to text as we
know now um uh so I'd like to explain
how to uh how to go about reading this
this
document um the um
uh they said there was some appendices
at the end that doesn't count as part of
the web description but web is a system
that will take a u that will take my web
source files and and then I run tangle
or weave on this uh on this source and I
get either a pascal program or a or Pech
program if I run tangle on I I'll
illustrate tangle in a minute if the
computer is up and um and if I run weave
on my web file I get this book well I
have to Tech it and then I get this
book um now let's see is the computer
yeah the computer seems to be up so
let's try switch over to the computer
screen and I'll illustrate what uh what
um tangle looks like when it's running
one thing you have to do in order to use
web is to uh is to have a tangle program
working um so we have the lights down
and uh we'll see if you can see the
computer
screen okay now let's see am I in the
right
file okay can you you see at the bottom
of the screen there I said um something
with tangle it's the contrast won't be
very very good but it's asking me for
well let's see we we should be able to
get that up higher in the screen in a
minute uh it's asking me for the name of
a web file and I will call for
Tango web that's on um on my area web DK
it's asking me for a change file the
change file is where you will put in
your modifications that that uh you
would want to use at particular
installation I'll just use null for a
change file Now can anyone see that at
all is it okay um uh now my output is
I'll putut on Tango PSC for example for
that's what we use for suffixes there
and it's asked me for a pool file also
and uh I don't need a pool file in this
case now a pool file is where you would
it would put strings if there were
strings uh strings in double quotes in
the listing that have more than length
one because Tang we we'll do this now
now let's see if we can watch it
operating here it's printing out as it
as it gets to a starred module these are
the ones that come out in bold face type
and in the table of contents in your web
listing it prints out the number of that
module as it gets to it so we can see
what it's doing and U it's tangling
itself right
now uh because it's tangling from Tango
web so this is converting the the the
web description of the program into a
pascal program and uh first of all it
reads the whole thing into memory into a
a very compact form inside of itself and
now it's right in the output file every
time it prints a DOT it's done 100 lines
of
output of Pascal
output okay so there um uh 500 okay you
got it and so uh then when we get the
output file we should be able to run
Pascal on that here it's also giving us
some statistics about uh uh let's see I
can put that up higher on the screen um
it told how large it's it needed for its
memory and it it stored that whole
tangle program in um uh approximately
18,000 tokens uh those are um 8 fit
those are those are 18,000 bytes to
represent the tangle program in its
compact form um plus the the what is
called bite memory and the tangle
program is is in is in one of those
handouts that you have
now um since we did that successfully
let's try the same thing on Tech so
we'll try the tangle
Tech and uh here we just Tech is a much
larger program but I have to show you
Illustrated graphically so we do this so
Tech web and again I won't use any
change file and we'll go to Tech
Pascal and now uh the pool file we'll
put it in text.
poool and uh or tech. pool of course and
then um uh in at our particular system
extensions like pool can only really be
three letters long so that's going to be
called
poo all right so it'll go run for a
while um but it uh but it'll be
generating the it'll be generating a
pascal source for uh for this
program now um now the web uh the
listing that you have the the of of tech
uh begins with a table of content so
very first as you open that cover you'll
see um that there's 55 parts to the
program and uh number one is the
introduction and the last one is the
index um
and uh so these are the major these are
the the major uh substructure to the as
far as as far as the uh as far as uh
Tech 82 is concerned um we're going to
be talking about for example string
handling part four that'll be one of the
things we talk about the next hour of
the lection um and uh I want to to
recommend that when you read this you
start in section one and then go to
number two and uh so on instead of
starting at uh section 400 and something
like this now there are some places to
start that are worse than others um and
I think uh the section on
alignment uh is is the worst of all uh
if you try to start reading Tech U by
learning how it does H align I think
that it might take well 400 hours
instead of 40 hours to understand what's
going on uh because alignment is done in
something like post hypnotic suggestion
uh by somebody who who who plants little
little uh uh ideas in to the other parts
of tech and every once in a while they
come into action and do the right thing
but it's uh but it stands in the
background most of the time and it's uh
and it sort of uh lets everything else
happen and automatically uh will rise to
the right occasion at the proper time
that's a um that's the the kind of thing
that that uh I I couldn't write first
and you shouldn't read first um but
especially I intended it to I I actually
presented this pretty much in the order
that I wrote the program um uh almost
almost in in that order because I I
wrote the program in a way that I felt U
um it called to be written um it it's
saying that now before I go any further
my mind won't be at ease unless I do
this I want to know how this is going to
happen I got to do this now and um that
or somehow I don't know exactly why I
felt that way but I did usually feel
rather strongly at what needed to be
done next and um I think also for
reading it uh similar similar questions
would be in your mind that this is what
you might want to know next as to to
what to do so it's a combination of a
bottom up and a top down approach where
first I go bottom up and build up a lot
of tools that I'm going to need later I
know I'm going to need those tools but
as I work on a particular tool I I
probably um uh approach the building of
that tool from a top down uh Direction
now the thing is is uh a total of 1244
modules at least at the present time and
after I finish debugging it it'll
probably be
1245 the uh um and these modules all are
numbered uh so you can see that uh
usually uh we get several modules on a
page um and uh as I turn over we can see
different you know different modules
over and over and each one has a nice
big bold face number on it and uh up in
the middle of the page here you'll be
able to see the part number and the
module number so for so uh there will be
a little section sign in between uh so
like this says 35 part 35 in module
number 652 okay
and uh this is the part that's doing
types setting a math
formula this whole listing of course was
generated by by
computer uh automatically from the web
file now the um the at the end we have
an index and the
index uh uh shows every occurrence of
every identifier in the
program um and then there's underlined
ones the underlined ones indicate where
that identifier was defined so let's
take this uh there's other things in the
index besides identifiers we talk about
those in a minute but let's take this
one empty so empty is defined here uh in
module 588 so 588 is underlined and it's
used in all of these modules here we ar
going to look them all up but let's
check check out 588 and see what empty
is is doing in 588 and it turns out that
uh there's a a definition of empty here
um uh both in in text where it explains
that what empty means um math type empty
indicates a field with no value oh you
can't see the the things that people on
the videotape can see I'm I'm I'm uh I'm
sorry I've been assuming that you could
you could read a little bit what I saw
what I see on my monitor here um okay
I'm um uh let's uh can we turn the
lights down and uh put the uh and and
give them on this screen what what what
I see on the monitor is that is that
possible can you can you see anything
that way well no I see it's it's it's
it's incompatible CU they need a light
to get the to get the camera to to read
this okay well forget
um um Meanwhile by the way Tech is
tangling up to um module number
749 and we're time sharing and getting
15% of the machine and the load is
4.5 okay now the uh uh anyway I I was
saying that if we look in the index you
um
um uh if you look in the index then uh
uh it should refer you to uh where
things are defined and um and all the
uses of them except if the if um letter
is only one if it's only one letter long
then the index only gives the underlined
uh references to it it doesn't give
anything else so if you see in the index
for example I probably have a a letter F
all by
itself um and so under F there will be
lots of underlined entries for f well
that's wherever F was used uh was was
declared probably as a parameter to a
procedure or local variable in a
procedure representing fonts uh because
the on letter identifiers are intended
are probably used so of off and then
nobody would care um uh to see them in
the index okay now the other things that
appear in the index are
um uh error
messages uh so if you if you see an
error message come out of tech and you
want to say well where in the heck was
that error message generated then this
will tell you what module uh to find
that and um a few few things you'll
find uh well reserved words you don't
often find in the index unless I
specifically said I wanted to indicate
that uh the word begin is used in this
module in some interesting way but
usually Pascal's uh other words of
course won't be indexed um by the time
the book is published we expect that
there will be a lot more entries in the
index that will that will uh ke key you
into where Tech does uh various
operations so if you want to uh see
where does Tech handle some something
like lowering a box or something like
that uh you might look under you might
look up in the index under lowering a
box and it might be there uh I'm going
to try to go through this this uh as I
do uh with other books and try to figure
out what ought to go into the index of
the book but I haven't done that yet
very much so the so other kinds of index
entries that are just in Roman type um
there are only a few of them so far um
and uh those those will be like you know
there's one entry here for Chinese
characters and it says Chinese character
are discussed in modules 128 457 500 and
you can um if you're interested in
extending text so that it would deal
with Chinese character suggestions for
doing that are in those are in those
modules um now each
module uh except the index has the same
basic structure to it um and it's a
three-part structure there's um uh the
first part is
Tech um second part is
definitions of macros and the third part
is
Pascal now the uh not all modules have
this have uh all three parts they can be
empty you might not have a tech part you
might not have a definition part you
might not have a pascal Park but if but
you never have more than one Tech Park
you never have a definitions after the
Pascal Park you never have Tech part you
know it always has that order Tech
definitions Pascal and they might be
absent um this is something that turned
out to be a fairly good uh uh a fairly
easy thing not only to implement but
also to to uh it was approximately the
way I was writing code when I when I
tested this this out when I uh when I
was sketching out the ideas of web last
fall um now the u tech part then is
expository it's supposed to It's
supposed to explain um either uh what
the whole idea of what's going on now
and in the future or it will explain
some um less obvious point about about
the code that follows perhaps telling
you the environment of the code telling
you what you what's supposed to be true
at this point reminding how we got here
uh things like that uh stat some kind of
an invariant of a loop that'll be there
explain why that Loop might be expected
to terminate um uh saying why uh it why
I didn't do such and such the the
comments at the beginning uh depend on
what I think are is worth saying I try
to think of something interesting to say
um in every module that has Pascal text
that's going to be contributed to the
main program anyway the um definition
part um defines macros I'll talk a
little bit more about that in a minute
uh that's a key thing to understanding a
a program written in web um and then of
then the Pascal part at the end is
Pascal code I try to shoot for about 12
lines of code in in in these as a
maximum um sometimes I go up a little
more but I try to keep it uh to
something that you can understand as a
unit the idea being that if you if you
have U Faithfully come into this module
from from the previous ones uh um you
should be able to know enough about it
uh about the current sub problem and
what and what you're supposed to do in
this module to fully understand it in
terms of uh in term these 12 lines just
by by looking at these back um maybe uh
uh uh your eye would go back and forth
over the 12 lines a few times and then
you say oh yes I got this this this
makes sense to me so the uh the modules
are small enough that the that you can
perceive their structure and perceive
the whole idea they refer to other
modules in different ways um let me see
I'll take a uh sort of a
random I I just turned to module one 180
uh which is on page 59 of your of your
uh of your handout uh this is I just
chose it at random and it said display
the value of glue set of p and so that's
a little module that um uh is is
actually uh I might tell you that it's
used when we're trying to print out um
uh p is pointing to a box we're trying
to print out what the glue setting is
this is the ratio of how much the glue
has to expand and if the the glue is
going to be expanding um uh by a
non-zero amount we want to indicate that
amount of expansion cuz we're going to
we're this is part of the diagnostic
output to explain what some one of TCH
data structures in symbolic form so uh
the code then says if glue set of p is
not zero then we will print comma glue
set now in those double quotes in the
print statement print uh double quote
comma glue set um
you um
uh uh uh you see that this is one of
those strings that I mentioned before
strings with double quotes Pascal uses
single quotes for Strings tangle makes
those strings and puts them into a
string pool file in fact it has finished
now and it said it wrote 897 strings to
the string pool file so there are there
are 897 different strings in the in the
program if if uh if I use the same
string several times it will uh of
course um uh do it only once now tangle
converts that to an integer um and the
integer that that it uses starts at
128 because the because 0 to 127 are are
reserved for the um uh Single Character
strings and uh there's an internal code
there's a and it's essentially asy code
that's used so that if you had a double
quote a UND double quote that always
refers to aski code of a it doesn't
refer to your local idic or whatever
code you might be using that always
refers to asky code of a we'll talk
about character set problems later on
when we talk about strings but uh that's
so so anyway this is a number so when I
says print um double quote glue set and
double quote that's really in the Pascal
file it's going to say print uh 428 or
some some other integer will be in the
Pascal
program um then we check and see if the
glue sign of p is shrinking and uh we
print uh a minus sign to indicate it
that the glue is shrinking instead of
stretching you see and then we have
problems to see whether what we print
out some value if it's real large then
we're going to print out
um
um greater than 20,000 or or less than
20,000 something like Anyway that's the
way the program works here and it says
at the bottom this code is used in
section 178 so if you need need to know
where this module um was applied it was
over here in module
178 178 indeed applied it here display
the value of blue set p and in that
module it that module was the display
box and so p is pointing to a box and we
and we and we have in this module the
problem is how to display a box and um
that breaks down into sub problems um
and so let's just read through that code
so you get the idea so you look at see
what kind of a box it is it's going to
be either an H list node or vlist node
we'll talk about data structure this
afternoon but that means it's an hbox or
V box essentially so we're either going
to print the H or V the H is going to be
the asky code uh H because this there's
a one one letter string you see um print
Escape means that it's going to prefix
it by a backs slash it's going to print
a back slash in an H otherwise if it's a
vlist node is printed back selection of
V otherwise there's something called
unset node uh which which is used in
alignments and then we have a box and a
left parenthesis then it'll print the
height of the box as a scaled number
we'll talk about these things later and
then it so it prints the dimensions the
height the depth and the width and then
it will check if it's an unset Noe it
has to do something special display
special fields of the unset node p and
that's module
179 uh which we don't care about for the
purpose for our purposes now we can say
okay that's going to be something that's
going to display those special Fields
otherwise
we will um display the value of glue set
P that's the one that we looked at first
and that'll say whether it's stretching
or shrinking unset nodes don't have glue
sets that's why we do it differently and
furthermore it don't have shift amount
this is whether the box was shifted up
or down or something like that and so we
check and see if it's shifted so that
finishes this module 178 it referred you
see to modules 179 to 180 but um if we
had to actually stick the code in there
it would be a distraction
um so we don't want to so for now we we
concentrate on what what do you do when
you display a box you have to go through
that many operations and then you've
done it uh this code is used in section
177 which indeed is called display node
p and uh it breaks down it's a case
statement that has many subcases um the
first three cases were H list node V
list node unset node said display box P
that's where we did this or we had to
display a rule or insertion or all these
things we have to possibly display play
and there's another module here that
fits into the case statement called
cases of show nodelist that arise in EM
only this is when you're trying to
display something in math mode and it
only occurs in math mode so we don't
even write it in this part of the tech
program since we only it's a person
reading it doesn't know about math modet
in fact when I wrote this part of it I
didn't know about math modet myself so I
just made a module and saying well I'm
going to handle those cases later and in
596 the um will will have indicated uh
what will the exposition will have
explained what what math mode is like
and so there will be display
instructions in in there and that will
be patched into the program uh by Tango
at this point so we'll have a case
statement that also includes other cases
for things like uh square root signs and
so on that that have to be displayed and
then um it says other cases print
unknown node type and this is uh
something I'll talk about about with
respect to uh what you do in case
statements in Pascal if they uh uh it
really means all other cases that
haven't been listed here and this code
was used in 176 and if we look at 176 it
doesn't tell us where it was
used in 176 it just ends at the bom says
it doesn't tell say where it was used if
it doesn't say where the code was used
this means it's it's really on bottom
level this is part of the whole Pascal
program
itself and so um some the things on
bottom level are strung together in the
order that they appear
here so this this module 176 will follow
the the pre the previous code for for
bottom
level in in the program any questions so
far on
this now the the macro definitions is
something I've got to uh talk about next
let's take a um a simple case of macro
there are three kinds of definitions and
they all say
Define um and uh the one is is numeric
definition and and then there are
um um uh there then there are
definitions that substitute with or
without parameters those are the three
kinds of definitions uh let's see if I
can find a u example okay numeric
definition I'm on page 51's module
number
156 um has lots of numeric definitions
um I'm laying out the memory and I'm
giving symbolic names to specific Parts
in the memory so
um uh I Define uh zero glue oh this is
not a numeric definition I'm sorry it
has a if it has three
lines uh if an equivalence instead of an
equal sign uh this means it's a it's a
text substitution because I uh uh if it
has if it's just an equal sign that
means it's a numeric thing which I'll
compute at uh at tangling time uh but uh
this is a teex substitution because M
base is a compile time constant that's
that that uh or it's uh it's something
anyway that that I didn't think I I
could uh necessarily know so I I've used
three arrows here and then I Define fill
glue to mean zero glue plus glue spec
size anyway those are these are things
that have been defined uh elsewhere this
is an example of a definition and
whenever I say temp head later on um
it's going to mean High m base + 3 and
um this mean this will be a more ponic
way to refer to T head it's and the
comment says it's ahead of a temporary
list of some
kind um so each of these things is we
try to explain it in words as as we
Define them uh on the previous page
you'll see a simple numeric definition
Define onset node as 13 so that's the
type for an unset node and that's
followed by uh the other two kinds of
definition so we have all three of them
in that module that's nice the um glue
glue shrink is to be substituted by
shift
amount which by the way is a macro
itself So eventually it'll propagate
down to to a lowlevel pascal code um
blue stretch of its parameter is M of
that parameter plus 6 dosc this allows
us to to refer to Pascal structure types
in a way that's that's pneumonic
indicating that we're really um looking
at um the sixth you know the seventh
word of a of a of something that start
starts in loc in a given location uh and
we're looking at it as a as a dosc field
of that word and that and if we were
rewriting text for some other uh uh some
other memory configuration um we would
only have to change this definition of
glue stretch and uh uh to say how we
actually are representing it in in in
whatever language we're really
programming in uh because the rest of
the the program just talks about glue
stretch of something and doesn't know
that it happens to be in words uh
something plus six of
that um so the these are the three kinds
of macros the uh the constant macros are
are restricted that these numbers can't
get too large I think it's something
like 15 bits plus a sign so that they uh
so that I shouldn't be I shouldn't
Define with an equal sign uh something
to be um I'll never Define with an equal
sign something that's a that's a number
are like U 50,000 I can do 30,000 okay
though um the advantage of those small
numbers is that I can do arithmetic on
them um and not put parenthesis around
the so uh if you do Tex substitution you
can have some troubles if you try to say
minus a macro and then that macro has
been defined to be X + Y without
parentheses um but if x but if it's the
macro has been defined with an equal
signs and and X and Y are numbers it
will add those numbers together and
it'll
work um now now uh I don't understand
how I know when I'm reading my program
which of these identifiers is a macro
and which isn't somehow um I've I've
never been confused by it uh but
possibly because I wrote the program
um uh and um it's something that uh is
is uh in the back of my mind to
experiment would there be a use for some
typographic distinction between names
that have been defined as a macro and
names that are really that are really uh
uh uh Pascal identifiers on the low
level everything eventually propagates
into a pascal code but um who knows uh
but but uh when when I'm reading a
program um on you know here in the
middle of module number 700 something um
and it refers to um glue stretch am I
supposed to know that it how do I know
that's not a procedure call U it's
really uh uh it has the you know it
looks like it might be a procedure call
with a parameter but it's really a macro
call with the parameter um well parently
uh I think it's because I'm when I'm
referring to Blue stretch I'm I
presumably know that it means that it's
a certain field of a record and I'm
always referring to fields of record
records V via macros so that I can have
a symbolic way to refer to them that's
doesn't uh that isn't too closely tied
to Pascal language
itself um but uh anyway some of the
identifiers you see in the program are
Pas are in the Pascal program others are
are macros and um uh if you as we uh if
you refer to the index of course it
tells you where it's defined and you can
always check exactly what it means um
now um I've written this so that in the
final Pascal program no two identifiers
will start with the same first seven
letters so so um uh Pascal's rule says
that they have to be distinct in their
first eight but I I made it seven uh
partly this helps me helps uh catch
typographic errors because if two things
agree um to seven if I have a
typographic ER and and it Tango will
print out that there was a that these
two variables have conflicting names and
it probably was that I that I
made a mistake in typing the at after
after the first seven letters um uh but
it also it's just because I've heard of
compilers that that actually put this
extra restriction on it the first seven
should be unique um but this also gives
a clue as to whether a name is is a
macroon name or not because macroon
names don't have to be distinct in their
for they can they can be 100 letters
long and the first 99 letters can agree
because macron names are done by tangle
not by Pascal and I implemented the full
full comparison of those names so um
whenever I have a a long identifier
which looks like it's it has very high
chance of conflicting with in its first
seven letters with something else then
that's another dead giveaway that it's a
macroon name because I would never dare
use such a such a an identifier and and
then freeze those those valuable first
seven letters for some other purpose
like uh
um I don't know uh we'll see examples of
that I'm
sure okay um now let's take a look at
the very beginning of the program and
see how it gets how it gets
started as I said uh the right way to
read this is is starting at module one
and going through um I'm not going to be
giving you homework exercises in these
lectures but um I would encourage you to
uh to do some reading tonight and
tomorrow night uh you'll probably get
more out of the lectures on Thursday and
Friday the introduction here is
primarily historic and um and uh there
is one definition at the bottom of the
page uh that defines the banner string
and here's something that will be source
of one of your system dependent changes
presumably you will um you will change
this so that a diversion number will
also indicate that that this is the vax
version or something else uh and then
this right now is version minus1 minus
.25 because it's not uh debugged yet
okay
then um uh I talk about the idea of
system dependent uh codes and and other
things that are in the index here in
section three and
uh and uh one of the things I mentioned
here in Section 3 is this idea of uh an
index entry that's called Dirty
Pascal um there were a few places where
I uh did things that aren't considered
kosher in Pascal and uh if we look up
dirty Pascal in the index it'll show you
those modules um and and the modules
will try to justify why they did the
thing they did usually it was for
debugging purposes uh where you had to
fetch out a record not knowing what it
was because something has gone gone
wrong but anyway if your compiler is
going to complain about those you'll
want to you you want to know about it um
part four is where we actually get going
and
um and uh let's and uh into the program
um it's uh and so here's where we first
start this is the first Pascal text
modules 1 to 3 didn't have any Pascal
text there was this one
definition and the very first thing well
we have a definition here that I could
explain mtype I defined to be t uh %an y
%an p %an e and this is a special web uh
thing that will it will concatenate
different identifiers together uh
without spaces between them and I'm
calling it mtype is typ the reason is
that I wanted very much to use type as
one of the uh macros that I was going to
Define later but it's a reserved word in
Pascal and so in order to do this I can
Define mtype uh for the one or two
places where I needed to uh use Pascal's
reserved word and then ever then
afterwards I I get to use type myself um
because there's a format which is a
special kind of a definition that says
that the mtype identifier should be
treated like Pascal treats type and type
should be treated like Pascal treats
true and so that will uh so for
formatting purposes I can make those
kind of definitions also um that's
that's a little uh thing for web now the
program itself starts here with compiler
Direct Ives in module 9 um then program
statement and gives the name of tech it
doesn't have any file names mentioned
there because if it did on our Pascal
anyway the user would have to type in
file names at that point and um uh
that's not the way Tech 82 does things
then comes the labels and there's a
listing for labels in the outer block
section six constants in the outer block
um types in the outer block this is
where I used my M type and you notice
now it gets format added in bold face
here and then ver VAR list globals in
the outer block then there's a procedure
declaration for the initialization and
initialized procedure is going to be
called to to get things going and then
there's a module called basic printing
procedures which we had to declare very
early in the
game um and error handling procedures
which we also have to declare early
because errors can occur almost anywhere
you have to declare your error handling
procedures soon but while you're doing
errors you have to print out what the
error is so you needed to printing
things even earlier and that uh
incidentally enforce the discipline that
when I'm printing anything out um I got
to do something that's not going to
that's not going to have a chance of
Errors going wrong so so uh when I write
my print procedure I'm not supposed to
overflow any buffers or anything that
would cause an error message that would
get the that that might uh get into a
loop okay now that's the way the program
starts and and uh module 5 explains how
it continues namely all the modules from
now on um is going to uh we're going to
have uh uh more Declarations of
procedures and finally there's going to
a place called start here where we start
um and that's going to be way at the end
because we're just going to build up
procedure after procedure after
procedure doing the things that Tech is
supposed to do and then at start here
it's going to say do it or something
like that you want to call initialize
and a few other things uh and then it
will also tell how to uh die gracefully
at the
end um so these modules are further
explained later on and um I have special
uh things declared in module 7 that's
for for different versions of the seven
and eight which are for different
versions of of the same program this is
all one program some of you have
experience with the previous the
previous uh h of tech and um the um and
um the uh and there were three programs
there was tech there was a system
dependent module and a and a
pre-processing module well all three
functions are combined in this one now
and even a few more and these and in
order to select out different things we
we can change these definitions of these
modules here I have debug and uh
backwards debug uh and if I put code
between debug and backwards debug it'll
be commented out normally because I've
I've declared debug to be at sign left
brace which is a real left brace to go
into the program and backwards he bug to
be a um a real right
brace this by incidentally um Tango will
will now change left braces to other
symbols so that it won't uh it will
still be a valid Pascal comment in
between those two braces but these two
bra or and if these were inside of other
braces these wouldn't actually come out
as braces they' come out as brackets um
but um this is this is now we we'll
will'll comment out all the code between
debug and backwards debug um similarly
there's statistics and backward
statistics uh that common out code that
would slow tech down but will keep uh
information about how big its tables are
getting and when you're installing a
system you want to find out how large uh
how much of your memory is actually
being used um you you'd like to to see
these statistics but it gets Rose if
people print them out all the time andow
the system down I think uh um well maybe
4 or 5% but maybe you wouldn't want to
pay that four or 5% if people aren't
using the statistics so that can also be
commented out and it's shown as
commented out here then here is
similarly is is is um the other version
of tech init and backwards init these
are things that are only present in the
initialization version of tech the one
that you need to get started because it
loads all of the hash table with The
Primitives and loads preloads formats
preloads macros so it it can put
everything into a condensed file for
efficient starting out of the production
program so you'll have two versions of
tech production program of tech and the
initialization called in Tech and to to
make any Tech you you
um youve got it because this is uh this
is not commented out but to get the
production version you have to put you
have to change this to braces and you do
this in your change file you never
change the the web file for Tech you you
you uh just make a change file for any
Tech a change file for production Tech
and you run tangle with one or the other
um now uh uh let's see that have there
will be other changes probably between
these also because in Tech you'll want
to to allow yourself um more room maybe
for hyphenation tables uh since you want
to see how big those are going to be and
uh and then afterwards when you have a
production Tech you you'll know that the
hyphenation tables aren't going to be
very big you can cut that that uh part
time parameter
down um so uh those are the three uh
things that can be compiled compiler
directives is something rather it most
pcal compilers if the comment starts
with a dollar sign it will do something
special like check uh range ranges or
not and and so on so I I've done that
now um I don't know what time is I I
can't see the clock in the back is can
someone tell me Buton engage it's 10:30
okay so I got only a few more minutes um
before we break um we started 5 minutes
late the um uh so let's take a look at
the uh what the computer has
done uh since we did start it out there
so you see that it came to a conclusion
and um in fact the um uh where it says
idle 25 minutes it means I haven't done
anything for 25 minutes but the two in
front of it says that that was 2 seconds
2 minutes of CPU time so it took exactly
2 minutes of CPU time to do this
tangling on on this deck 10 um and uh it
had little more than 4,500 lines of
Pascal code and the um the numbers here
the number of tokens here was was more
like um um
110,000 um bytes uh in order to to do
the compressed thing in memory and also
called tokens and then things that were
called bites those are generally
strings um and uh and names of
identifiers U and there's lots of those
too and this is a this is a rather large
uh order for tangle to fill but uh it it
isn't too bad now uh let's take a look
at the Pascal program that that um uh
was was generated so that's see Tech
ascal
uh this should be 4500 and some lines
long and
um take a little while to read in to for
the editor to read it all in because
it's a page oriented editor and the
larger the page is the longer it takes
now um I just wanted to count how many
semicolons are in this listing so we can
get some idea as to how long it is I've
never done this before I wanted to find
out how big Tech how big Tech is so it
starts out with the with the program and
uh you'll see also that there's things
in braces there indicating uh what
module it came from so if you can read
uh um uh the brace 9 that that was that
was because this code was generated by
the compiler directives uh which was
module 9 and in module 9 it um it
commented something out um and then that
bracket there uh was a com was a Brack
was a brace inside of a bracket so then
we get a program Tech and it says label
and then the comment six says that those
labels in the outer block are in module
6 see see how that works now let's see
if I if I search for a um uh search for
a semicolon now I'm going to search and
see how many semicolons it can
find uh just to see how many semicolons
are in this listing this is the way the
Pascal uh uh program looks and it's 45
56 lines right now each it's all
uppercase letters except where we have a
uh in strings if somebody's Pascal
doesn't accept uppercase letters they
would have to uh do system dependent
changes on the strings in in quotes you
can see that Tech sources has a few
lowercase letters there um all the lines
are 72 uh characters uh or less okay now
it found
10,928 um um
semicolons um and uh so that's
approximately 11,000 statements and
declarations in this program except that
the word else also contributes so if I
search for else I can find some more so
let's try
else
um see if see how many occurrences of
else there are in the program uh 664 so
that add another okay so so
approximately U oh not quite
12,000 um statements and declarations
are are in this program uh and um okay
the the corresponding figure for salale
Tech was 5,000 so I just trying to um uh
understand the difference now now salale
Tech uh um used um declarations it would
declare a lot of variables at the same
time with commas in between them instead
of having one line per declaration so
that might account for this um but the
if you look at if you want to know about
the size of this compared to PTEC it's a
little shorter than than uh the pte plus
C CIS de so it's a it's approximately uh
it's actually gotten smaller uh than the
uh than the existing version of tech so
I believe the compilers will will be
able to handle it okay well um if there
are any Qui quick questions I can handle
them otherwise we'll start uh we'll
break for half an hour and I can't see
oh yeah there's one what's format oh a
format you you give identifier
equivalent to another identifier the
first identifier is the is um um the one
you want to be using the second one is
the one that that that you want it to
format like so if you so I so I
formatted debug as begin I said format
debug equal equivalent to begin and that
means that when Tech sees debug it
should um enter a new level of
indentation uh and put it in bold face
like it does for begin and and backwards
debug I made like
end and and so when what usually uh when
I Define a an identif a macro I'll just
uh I'll just want U it to be treated in
the normal Garden
vanilla the normal way that all identifi
are treated but if I want some special
treatment um I can say treat it like a
certain Pascal reserved
word yeah the web manual is uh eight
pages long so those rules are all given
there in detail but so at the very
beginning we have uh as you know in most
program at the very beginning you there
are features that are only used once for
understanding Tech itself those little
fine points of web programming aren't
going to be aren't going to be important
but if you want to know exactly what's
going on then um uh then those those
things do
arise any other yes
why okay P the question is why use pasc
constants in some place and and Define
numbers in others and the answer is I I
made Pascal constants in the places
where I felt uh the user uh could could
change them at compile time and nothing
else would go wrong and so this was the
distinction this is a Val I think a
valuable distinction to have uh so the
things that are constant in that Pascal
program you should be able to change
that number and at and recompile without
doing anything to your web file or
anything um now but uh uh the to have
the actual definitions it was possible
for me to get around a lot of other of
Pascal's restrictions for example Pascal
doesn't allow you to to have an array
boundary that's something minus
one and uh by but by declaring it as a
web macro I can subtract one from it and
Tangle will will will do the arithmetic
and and it'll come out fine in my
program so uh that's why I I've used uh
web to get around these uh these
problems with Pascal
language it's done correctly in Ada and
I wouldn't have had to do that in Ada I
might have done a different a different
you know on some other things
L what is the format of Chang file
change oh the format of a change file is
that uh is that lines should match see
can we get that up on let's take a look
at tech. change we didn't use the tech.
chain here but
um um now this is a page oriented editor
and so the first page is is an index to
the rest of the is the index to the rest
of the file and and so um it shows you
the first line of page two the first
line of Page Three and so on here's page
two which um which um is the first
change I made and um the and I just
repeat uh verbatim a line that's in
tech. web and then uh and then I made a
um and then I made a correction uh so
the first first line matched then it
goes on until the line that says at sign
Z at the bottom
there um and um and you see I um I my
change here was only to put an S in the
version number uh it's a version minus
0.25s for Stanford I guess or sale or
something because sale stands for
Stanford artificial intelligence lab and
um and then these are index entries by
the way here um extensions to Tech um uh
this at sign up arrow is an is something
that goes in the index and I and at sign
up Arrow system dependencies changes for
sale in um median caps font um uh I
every time I put something in my change
file I also put an index entry saying
this is this is a change that I made so
that when I look at the index that I
would weave from this I could find all
the all the modules that I've changed
now the next module starts out
um uh with debug and backwards debug and
then I copied it exactly except that I
did change it for for
debugging uh so that the it isn't braces
it's
blank um and so on so all of these
changes just start out with a uh thing
here I use a special switch on our on
our compiler a w switch which makes it
uh um catch the kind of errors that IBM
Pascal catches that our that our
compiler doesn't ordinarily
catch so we should think about the
change file being merg with yes yes yes
yeah the that's the idea that the uh
change file is a small number of changes
that uh will probably uh that that you
can keep on fiddling with until you get
it to work with your present web file
then when you get the real web file
later on probably your your change file
will still work with it and so the all
the system dependent this uh could
extend to U multiple change files but uh
we but since we're listing all our files
at the beginning of the tangle run uh
right now we we only have uh exactly one
web file and one change file every time
we run tangle okay so the so this this
change file is given on the tape that
you get for Tech as an example of uh of
of one change file that was done I've
done I've made it here U um if you look
at I I for example I the memory Max has
been changed to 1,000 that's not enough
to do any user jobs for teching but it's
very good for debugging because when
you're debugging uh uh you want to you
want the program to get into its
complicated cases where it has to try
hard to find to find free memory now I
have that first happen a few months
later okay question over there you
describe how L and the web file when
doing a change get
deleted okay yeah so soon as it finds a
matching line like so uh um so tangle
reads this this first line into a buffer
the following parameters and so on keeps
it in a buffer every time it reads in a
a line from the other file from the web
file it Compares those two buffers if
they agree I think it'll it'll do
something like I not care about blank
spaces at the end or something but if
they agree exactly then it starts
reading the change file and continues um
the change file until it comes to at
sign Z at the beginning of a line um it
deletes all the stuff in the web up till
the beginning of the next
module in this way you would be able to
substitute more than one module for for
a uh you know your change file could
generate five modules uh for the for
only the one and the other but we
discourage this because then all your
numbers will be off and you and why you
know why why do that so at the very end
uh just before the index there's a
module called system dependencies and
and this is and uh so so that's where um
system dependent changes this module
should be replaced by changes to the
program that are necessary and and and
here's where uh you you try to gather
all of the all of the uh changes that
that are going to require new modules to
be made that way uh the this will be the
only one that changes the numbering
system and only the index then will will
really be
misnumbered nothing else will Bo will be
will bother you there okay well we
better break now and uh meet again at
11:00 sharp for the second session
thanks very
much